Hello america it's been a long time since i
donned the old secret identity but trust me
it's me homelander now look there's been
a little drama around vaught of lake but
i want to reassure you here and now
superheroes are still the good guys
we're not perfect i mean i've ran through a
girl but only because she stepped off the curb
and into the middle of the street like a crazy
person but we all make mistakes and that's why
pencils have erasers right i want to go ahead
and apologize for a trains comments but the
point is being a superhero is about saving lives
being an inspiration and rescuing the dolphins
you won't leave alone actually what i was going to
say was that okay are we uh are we going okay hey
um so did a train just say that killing robin is
why pencils have erasers uh yeah that's pretty up
sorry for the interruption okay i wasn't
finished the thing we need to focus on
is making america safe again and the only way
to do that is more superheroes oh hi there as
a member of the church of the collective i can
assure you there's a larger plan for all of us
and if you enroll in our church classes for
the low price of seventeen hundred dollars
each we'll tell you what that plan is but the
point is there's absolutely nothing to fear
we got photos of that dude with a
manatee but you're gonna listen to him
there is a new wave of soup terrorists and we are
the only ones who can stop them that's why going
back to my previous point superheroes are about
murder if you look at them wrong they will kill
you what he's trying to say is that soups are
bad okay i mean except for uh one of them all
right all right okay look there's nothing to be
afraid of i mean we're not that different from you
at the end of the day we are tax paying gas
pumping american citizens just like you okay
let's not get carried away because people they
want someone who's stronger and generally better
than them in every single conceivable way after
all who else is going to save you but don't take
it from me take it from this guy hello america
as the original superhero i assure you that you
are in safe hands with us i'm soldier boy and i
approve this message god bless you soldier boy
translucent
blew him up in the ass man i'm gonna go
Welcome back everyone this is gonna be the boys
season 3 teaser video as well as a breakdown of
herogasm they just announced there's a bunch
of big stuff happening during season 3 so
i'll explain what's going on with jensen ackles
and some of the storylines that they've already
talked about if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i will
be doing videos for all the season 3 episodes just
like season two and obviously it's only going to
get more and more wtf as the series goes on
and the good news is they did say that they
have several more seasons in them so it's not like
they're going to be ending the show anytime soon
i'll explain the funnier herogasm stuff they
were posting about more recently the writers
the showrunner were just talking more and more
about how they're going to do that version of the
comic book storyline for tv obviously it's going
to be a little bit different because it's so over
the top crazy the whole thing the show runner was
posting about recently though was the completion
of episode six which is titled herogasm so that's
when they're going to be doing that actual story
the way the showrunner actually explained their
version of herogasm is that he said that the
minute that he announced that he was doing the tv
show everybody even his friends inside hollywood
his other showrunner friends were challenging him
daring him to do the herogasm you'll never be able
to do this so this is him just celebrating
the fact that he accepted that challenge
and completed it if you've never read the boys
comic book hero gasm is basically like the worst
possible version of spring break that you could
imagine but just for superheroes compound v
superheroes it's like this giant week-long event
where they all go they're all just doing with
each other indiscriminately just doing drugs
all over the place i guess depending on how
you think about it it could be the best version
or the worst nightmare version of spring break
no judgment there everybody loves to have fun
during spring break at some point but the story
line coincides with a lot of what they're doing
with the other storylines during season 3 in the
comic book plot that they're adapting because now
we're sort of moving into the superheroes in the
government storyline from the comics which
is a little bit later in the comic book run
but also as part of the hero gasms storyline you
have the soldier boys storyline and obviously
jensen ackel is going to be their version
of soldier boy during season 3. the whole
connection the reason why jensen ackles is coming
to the boys is because the showrunner eric kripke
was also the creator of supernatural so that's why
you've seen a lot of supernatural actors show up
on the boys in previous seasons like you have jim
beaver's bobby singer character i think his name
is actually bobby singer on the tv show which was
his name on the supernatural tv show all they got
to do now is get jared patalecki at some point
even though he's off doing that other new show
post supernatural there's also a bunch of timeless
actors on the tv show too because eric kripke also
created the timeless tv show like victoria newman
i think was on timeless i'll talk about her in a
second too because she's obviously a really big
character during season 3 then you also have the
alastair character who is a bit of an antagonist
press f in the chat to pay respects to him
but the whole thing with soldier boy is they
are changing his character from the comics
what they're doing is they're using him as a more
legit straight up version of their captain america
in the comics there are two different versions
of soldier boy there's the original version who
was created as a compound v superhero during world
war ii he was america's first attempt at creating
their own superhero he wound up being terrible at
his job he got a bunch of his squad mates killed
he actually fought with mallory who in the
comics is a much older version of the character
and winds up killing the original soldier boy as
retaliation for getting his squad killed through
his incompetence later in the present day of the
comics there's a soldier boy 2 who just wears the
mantle of soldier boy but he's a completely
different character he winds up working with
the payback team episode 1 of the boy season 3 is
confirmed to be payback so they're obviously doing
the payback team the payback team in the comics
is a direct reference to marvel's avengers team
but what they're doing on the tv show with jensen
ackle's version of the character is they're sort
of combining the original soldier boy and the
newer soldier boy and he's going to be more like a
version of captain america and the reason why stan
edgar is bringing this original soldier boy back
the jensen ackles version is a sort of response
to the big regime change in the changing sentiment
about superheroes is a direct response to how
pissed off they are about what happened with
stormfront you notice the way they spin things in
that conference at the end of the season they all
kind of turn on stormfront like we had no idea
what she was doing this whole time this was all
her fault how dare she try to pull this over
on us when really stan edgar knew exactly what
was happening the entire time so swinging to the
opposite end of the spectrum he's bringing back
the most fan favorite patriotic seeming superhero
of all time the only superhero that vaught has
that was as popular as homelander is right now but
just to be clear homelander is still the strongest
superhero on the planet but the thing is is that
they're all kind of keeping each other in check
because now everyone has all this evidence against
homeland or they'll release and they know that
homelander who's going completely off the deep end
at this point jerking off on top of the chrysler
building is like one step away from lasering all
of them so this sort of this cold war situation
now that's happening between the boys fought
with stan edgar homelander and now queen maven
starlight which are back on the seven to keep an
eye on vought from inside the belly of the beast
the whole thing with victoria newman though is
that she is sort of a version of the comic book
vic the veep character who was a former ceo of
vaught and it sounds like this might be part of
their superheroes in the government storyline
the whole thing that vat wants stan edgar wants
is to get superheroes in the white house because
that's how they influence real policy that's how
they gain real power so that might be part of
the reason why victoria newman wound up killing
alastair at the end of season two because he had
all this dirt on vought he was ready to release
like all right let's do this let's take them down
why would she stop that if she weren't trying
to keep vaught in power themselves early theory
the reason why she wants to keep vauden power is
because she's also working with stan edgar and she
wants to keep them around creating new superheroes
because it'll give her new agency the one that
regulates superheroes more opportunities for wins
thus advancing her political career getting her
closer to the white house eventually she's also
got one of those homelander itchy trigger fingers
with her powers where he loves to laser people on
the spot as many chances as he can get she loves
to pop people's heads as many chances as she gets
i know everybody's wondering what happened to
cindy at the end of the season because we last
see her getting in a car just driving off into
the distance so cindy is still in play the way the
writers and the show owner explain that is that
it's just sort of a bomb that they set off in the
wild to see if it goes off later so this is that
they might bring cindy back in a future season but
they didn't confirm that that would be during
season 3 they also confirmed that stormfront
is definitely not dead she's getting the anakin
skywalker crispy chicken darth vader treatment
it's exactly what homelander said during that last
press conference she is being kept in a secure
facility and vada's going to have some creative
punishment for her because she is regenerating
but she's not growing her limbs back you'd be
surprised though what they can do with compound
b they can actually bring superheroes back from
the dead with compound v legit ryan is also now
under the care of the newly rebuilt government
approved version of the boys mallory has now been
empowered in a way with more funding than she ever
was before so she's actually able to legit help
butchering the boys in a way that they couldn't
do before they'll just continue developing his
powers him learning about how to use them because
currently even stan edgar acknowledges this with
butcher in their conversation ryan is the only
deterrent that they have for homelander the only
superhero potentially powerful enough to take
him down the way that child actors age up pretty
quickly i wouldn't be surprised if by the end of
the series their endgame is very darth vader luke
skywalker standoff moment with homelander and his
son because by the end of the series maybe season
5 season 6 or whatever they wind up going to ryan
will look like a teenager big enough to actually
challenge homelander but everyone post all your
theories about season 3 in the comments below
obviously it's going to be off the chain they
didn't say exactly when it's going to premiere
but they're going to be filming really
soon so hopefully they can speed through
episodes and get them out by the end of this
year my new marvel Wandavision episode 3 video
will post on friday that's obviously the big show
that's on right now you can click here for all my
boys season 2 episodes and you can click here
for my wandavision episode 1 in episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!